So let's see if we can figure what
the problems are with UMA aka SMP
aka Multicore.
Let's suppose that we want
to have a lot of cores and
have them use this centralized
shared memory in a UMA SMP fashion.
Which of these are problems we'll
have to face when we do this?
First, memory needs to be very large and
thus slow for this type of a machine.
Our main memory will get too
many accesses per second.
Basically, we'll need a huge memory
throughput that a normal memory module
will not be able to provide.
The next option is,
we'll need a lot of small memory modules
in proportion to the number of cores.
Next, our caches will have
very small block sizes.
And finally, the pages for
our virtual memory will become
too small to be usable.
So, select all of those that are
problems for this type of architecture.